Abagail Thernstrom co-author of no
excuses closing the racial gap and
learning what's the reason that you
decided to do this book well I decided
to do the book because the racial gap is
it seems to us the domestic problem
education continues of course in the
eyes of most Americans to be the number
one domestic issue but what race
continues to be the American dilemma and
we will never get to racial equality in
the society as long as we continue to
have a staggering racial gap in academic
achievement between whites and Asians on
the one hand blacks and Hispanics on the
other hand it is really the source of
ongoing racial inequality in America how
why does the gap the gap is appalling at
the end of high school
a typical african-american or Latino
student is about four years behind
depends on the subject a little science
is five years four years behind the
average white or Asian student and that
means that those youngsters are
graduating from high school with a
junior high school education at going on
to college or you're going into the
workplace with 7th or 8th grade skills
our best source of information is the
National Assessment of Educational
Progress it's the nation's report card
on on education that's called nape and
nobody disputes the nape numbers and
when you test 12th graders typical again
these are averages typical black
youngster is scoring below 80 percent of
his or her white and Asian classmates
Hispanics doing a little better not much
better it is a different story with
Hispanics I could go on with with number
seven you look the majority of black
students make this got seven tests
on five of them majority of black
students fall into the lowest category
which is below basic that means they
don't even have a partial knowledge of
the fundamental skills that they need to
do well in American society and if you
look if you look at the top students at
the very top instead of looking at the
below basic if you read top category is
advanced and you take for instance math
percentage of black kids falling into
the advanced category in math its 0.2%
falling into that advanced category the
whites
number of whites 11 times as large
number of Asians 37 times as large these
are these are very bad numbers and again
they do have long wrong meaning for
these youngsters because it is very hard
to catch up after age 18 you have some
statistics in your book 37 percent of
black children live with two parents 77
percent of white students live with two
parents right 65 percent of Hispanics
live with two parents and 81 percent of
Asians live with two parents how much
does that have to do it does make a
difference there are strong correlations
between single-parent households birth
to a young mother educate parental
education place of residence and and
performance on these standards based
tests of academic achievement but it
isn't the whole story when you control
for all the demographic factors and I
should say it's not possible to control
with total scientific accuracy because
because there are subtleties here you're
going to miss in for instance looking at
the relation
between income and test scores you
generally looking at free lunch yell
ability eligibility well free lunch
eligibility covers a wide spectrum of
family income levels but nevertheless
all of these factors do have something
to do with academic achievement but they
explain only about a third of the gap so
that you're left with two thirds
unexplained by your normal you know by
poverty by family structure my place of
residence by education I think it's safe
to assume that you are enamored by
somebody by the name of Esquith yes that
teacher full name race Escalus where
does he live in Los Angeles what does he
do
well he in effect runs a one-room
schoolhouse in a though principal of the
school would not like it to be described
as such in a very large elementary
school in Central LA called the hobart
elementary school and there are twelve
fifth grades he has just one of them and
he he is able to get away with running
his own program in every sense of the
word in terms of curriculum in terms of
the hours that children attend in terms
of the length of the year terms of what
they do with their time and so forth
only because he has gotten a tremendous
amount of publicity over the years and
so and a lot of things very good at
fundraising so school and the district
leave him alone you have to be a kind of
crazy man like he is in the best sense
um to to get away with what he does he
is there it's got become a little later
now but he's there at roughly 6:30 in
the morning every morning and he says to
his student well you have to come cute
this a regular public school
starts at 8 o'clock you come when you
want but I'm going to be here at 6:30
teaching math so you want to come and
join us delighted and after school this
school has almost no sports he's got um
he's got fitted for his kids but he also
has something called the Hobart
shakespeareans and he all of his
children have English as a second
language
they are either Korean or they are
Hispanic called Latino in in California
and he just he decided many years ago
these children have to learn English how
are they going to learn English let's
read Shakespeare and so he started doing
so and he he puts on Shakespearean
productions every spring they are on a
stage they are in costume they're just
in the classroom but he's become very
famous for them because they are
spectacular I mean I I went several
times during the year two years ago to
see his King Lear develop and to see the
kids start out you know line by line
talking about it well what does this
mean and why would these words used and
does this really have implicit stage
directions you know in it does the
dialogue and I watch it at various
stages and when I went back for the
production and I have to say I was in
tears for watching it and it's because
5th graders and I had called my husband
Steven who my co-author on this book I
had called him after I first saw the
kids reading later I had called him from
a little balcony outside of race
classroom and I said you won't believe
what I've seen fifth greatest a reading
King Lear and Steve said don't be
ridiculous
that is pretentious and ridiculous and I
said Steve you have to see it so he came
saw it and he said oh my god I can't
believe this race race has done a
wonderful job but he's not interested in
running a school he nobody copies him in
the school nobody pays attention to him
I went to the 5th grade next door one
day just right next to his classroom
and he said so the teacher said to even
watching where's classroom and I said
yes it's unbelievable and he said yeah
it's very good I said so you could do
some of those things that was perfectly
clean nothing was going on in his
classroom I said you could do some of
those things I mean this is a you know
what isn't really so hard to do read
great literature with a book of and
rayful Phil reads Mark Twain and so
forth and he said yeah I mean it's an
enormous amount of work he's there
working with his kids on Saturday
morning his kids come to his house on
Saturdays and they work on the music for
everybody everybody has a part in these
plays because everybody plays at least
plays music and he adds the Beatles to
Shakespeare and music that the kids like
and so forth
and it's an amazing experience but he
does more than teach and this is true of
all the schools that we talk about they
do more than teach reading writing
arithmetic they do more than zeroing in
on the core academic subjects which one
does have to do and relentlessly with
kids who come to school with so little
he's into um in some fundamental ways
putting these kids on a different track
in life and teaching them what the rules
of getting ahead in America are I just
got a Christmas card from one of the
children he has every child in his class
write a Christmas card to somebody who
has been to the classroom written about
the class so this was a lovely card now
it just to me from one of the students
if you go to the classroom when you
after you've left all the kids sign a
card saying thank you for coming they
have to dress properly they have to
speak English properly they have to get
there on time they have to learn a code
of self-discipline they have to clean
their room things to scrub the tables
and make sure it's at home for them and
a lot of those kids never want to go
home do you have to
volunteer for the class um how do you
get in it you get at the school assigned
to you but there are a lot of kids who
have joined the Shakespeare production
in fourth grade and and really campaign
to get in the class but the school
assigns you and a lot of the kids are
considered academic losers
it's called Hobart elementary elementary
school and is located where in Central
Los Angeles it's really Koreatown and
race esketh is hold race has got to be
mid 40s now how long has you been doing
this since college well no he's been
teaching since since college he's always
been doing this though for well he
started out in an affluent school and
then somebody challenged him to to take
on the kids that were hard to teach he's
been doing this for twenty years almost
so what happens to these kids after they
leave this earth great well he keeps
track of him he has SAT preparation and
by the way he does a lot of testing
preparation in the in the classroom and
he has the kids get on to the tricks the
testers means to try to trap kids so the
way questions are phrased so that you
get just you get you get misled and you
can you end up with a long answer um he
continues offering SAT preparation
he he he goes on college tours with his
graduates when they get to the
appropriate age he's raised enough money
to be able to do that give him money um
various benefactors who are enamored
with with his class he's um I mean he's
very good at advertising it is what he's
doing and and that's a special skill all
in itself does he personally benefit
from
no doesn't make any more than any other
teacher now he makes less than other
teachers because well for a number of
reasons one he's refused to get these
Mickey Mouse meaningless degrees that
get you bumped up the ladder and
professional development points and so
forth em but also I mean there are
absurd things that have gone on in the
school like the law Shakespeare Company
one year asked him to bring his kids to
to London and put on you know all in the
industry of low production and raced
painless doc for being absent from
school no he does this because he's a I
called the sink in a masochist and I do
we do argue but we did ascribe a number
of schools he's the only single teacher
we describe but I mean one of the
arguments I make or we make in the book
I should say is and it happens today I'm
the one who visited all the schools so
that's one reason I is good education
cannot depend on these extraordinary
people who are willing to devote their
lives to these kids let me ask you it
might sound like an odd question I Mary
Francis very read this book I say if uh
if she been I was going to say you have
more news I don't have yeah YouTube
tangled civil rights commission she's
the chairman you remember how long have
you been a member in civil rights
commission January of 2001 and what is
it by the what does it do it's a federal
agency it was created in 1957 and the
fifty-seven Civil Rights Act to monitor
um Civil Rights right report amount of
the state of civil rights right reports
it doesn't have any enforcement powers
but we hold hearings and we do issue
reports and we do with you press
releases and you know this well the
government the government agitators to
support every
ask the question away Mary Francis Brady
chairman is an African American and I
just from your experience and knowing
what she thinks and all if she read this
book what would she agree with or
disagree with strongly just based on
what you know I think what she would
strongly disagree with I'm not sure what
she would agree with about what she
would strongly disagree with is a is our
skepticism about the degree to which you
can say in 2003 that racism explains the
racial gap and more broadly racial
ongoing racial inequality in the society
um it you know that obviously was true
yesterday and we don't think it's true
today America has changed and when
you're looking at the racial gap in our
view you're not basically looking at a
problem of ongoing racism I think she
would very strongly disagree with that
if you were to put your finger on the
one I know there's more than one the one
thing the biggest thing that has caused
difficulty for and in this particular
case black kids what would it be
if I preferred in question not to say
one thing but if I had to say one thing
except there is a radical disconnect
from the world of academic achievement
on the part of black too many black kids
and their families so they're frankly
not working hard enough why is their
district well I don't think we can
completely answer that question but we
can say a couple of obvious things like
education traditionally in this country
until very recently never got
african-americans very far up that
ladder of social mobility when there
our grave limits to where you could go
and of course most blacks lived himself
and until way after Brown vs. Board I
mean in the deep south until the very
late 1960 schools were totally
segregated and those were not only
segregated they were inferior vastly
inferior there's a lot of romanticism
today about those old all-black schools
don't get romantic they were terrible
and so the message was something not
delivered that you work hard in school
and doors are open to you you can go for
that is true today
I mean equal skills and knowledge not
equal years spending warming a seat in a
classroom but actual skills and
knowledge equal skillful knowledge equal
earnings and that was not true yesterday
it's not true until very recently it
really is today but the message needs to
be delivered very strongly to it to
black kids and you know very few schools
that are doing so in part because the
teachers don't believe it do you live in
Cambridge Massachusetts don't kind of in
Lexington Lexington is right near
Cambridge though Cambridge where Harvard
is my husband teaches at Harvard the
reason I bring this up is it did I read
it right that in Cambridge Massachusetts
they spend seventeen thousand dollars
per student and the national average
isn't six thousand if you read it right
is the highest of about a money spending
anywhere in the country I don't know if
it's actually the highest but it's up
there what's the racial mix of Cambridge
oh it's got a substantial black
population I can't I on a substantial
kind of population I can't remember
precisely the numbers at the moment but
substantial and the racial gap in
Cambridge is as bad as it is in
um what actually worse and in all sorts
of low-income communities that spend
half as much on education um in
Cambridge is it's got itself on a moral
pedestal and it's just doing horribly in
schools what's the moral pedestal
well moral pedestal Cambridge thinks
that it's full of progressive ideas
about education and progressive ideas
about equality and in fact it's not
delivering the education that makes for
real equality does anybody acknowledge
that well we do have a quotation in the
book from the superintendent saying yeah
I know we got to do something about it
but the fact is they aren't doing
anything sensible about it and they're
now starting dropping the bussing on the
basis of your skin colour which it was
their previous solution and which of
course got them nowhere busing is I like
integrated schools all other things
being equal to [ __ ] doesn't doesn't
raise the level of achievement so now
they're going to start busting on the
basis of social class and I have a very
simple view of that stop moving the kids
around and teach them that doesn't seem
to have occurred to Cambridge and
they're all into very progressive
notions about not having not sorting the
kids on the basis of academic
achievement and not having kids mmm
well my times table because that's rote
learning
um you learn what you are interested in
when you're ready to learn it it's an
educational disaster as far as I can
tell
Kip Kay IPP stands for what knowledge is
power program
I understand there's something called a
key Academy right here in Washington but
you talk about a Kipp school in Houston
among others how many of them are there
I think we're there up to third
to this year but I thought it could be
slightly high and in case they've got to
think that's right they've got a big
replication project they started in
Houston and I talked more actually about
the school in the South Bronx in New
York which I really know well I physical
Angels just called Kipp Academy because
you see the first two schools were the
only kids
so with Kipp New York and Kipp Houston
this was the replication project is
really fairly recent when do they start
it no I say about three years ago now
something like that um it's the Fisher
foundation which is gap money and gap um
the clothes you wear something where
anyway maybe you don't in anybody
particular behind that I mean any any
people they're running the whole
operation uh yes they've got yeah they
hired a staff and Mike Feinberg actually
has run out of San Francisco has just
left there and going back to Houston but
he won't hand David Levin David leaven
of Bronx on Kipp they were the two
originators of the Kipp academies and
Feinberg was very important in
sandwiches go and tell this year now I
should say visit this is an incredible
story because find Bergen Levin
University of Pennsylvania graduate Yale
graduate 11 was and they were just kids
we went into Teach for America and they
ended up teaching together in Houston
and they looked at each other I mean
they're not 25 years old yet at this
point they looked at each other and said
we can do better than this
um and so I started in school in Houston
and after a year Dave went to New York
and started the school only on one floor
of a school that has three other schools
in it
same demographic group I'm going from
the same demographic population only
very quickly he got neither kids out of
the Bronx project these are kids who
would coming to school with it nothing
it's a middle school coming to school
not knowing how to read he very quickly
got the highest math scores and all of
the Bronx second-highest in New York
City when he arrived he said when he
managed to persuade the New York City
authorities to let him try this he said
but you're not sending me teachers in
the usual way that teachers are simply
sent from the central office and
principals don't have a say or the team
that they've got working for them one of
the little public school disasters that
that really impedes learning did you not
send me pictures from a central office
and they said oh yes we are
and he said fine I'm just going to open
with 45 children and I'm going to teach
them all myself so choose am I going to
be the only teacher is gonna let me pick
teachers just a public school by the way
it for five years it was a regular
public school and now he's become a
charter school which turned out to be
essential he needed the autonomy and the
authority and you could only have in a
charter school control over sellers
control of his budgets not fighting with
the central office all the time I mean I
was with him for a day he was up in
Massachusetts I was with him for a day
which I really wanted to talk to him and
he spent the day arguing with the
bureaucracy about whether his kids to
have a morning snack had to go for
flights down to the cafeteria or whether
somebody would deliver their morning
snack on the fourth floor so that they
didn't have to interrupt the school day
and and lose learning time the kids in
kid do not lose learning tell me going
to any other school wait let me ask you
define what a charter school is I think
you say in your book that there's 36
states that have charter schools in them
and I'll possibly find the numbers and
large numbers and the thousands of
charter schools what are they they are
public schools they're often people
referred to public schools and then
charter schools no charter schools are
public schools but they are chartered is
when the state laws all differ from
state to state you have different
charter school laws and some are much
better than others in Massachusetts
where I'm on the State Board of
Education it is the state board that
charter schools gives a charter to a
group that comes to us and says look
we've got an idea for a school this is
you know here is a total plan this is
what we're going to do and this is what
we promise in the way of results and
they are accountable for those results
they will be closed they don't come
through we closed the charter school
last year in Massachusetts but in
exchange they have enormous economy so
the accountability is attached to
freedom yep you have the freedom you're
out from under the collective bargaining
agreements very very important you don't
belong to a union now the teachers do
not belong to you because they cannot or
the unions Canadians organize them no
under what law well I mean that's part
of the charter school that these schools
are free to be non-union I mean can it
no the unions wouldn't try because these
are teachers who are going to a school
in order to be out from under the under
the Union we make more or less than a
normal public school they are the
charter schools in general by the way
have smaller budgets that although they
can supplement them by fundraising but
they have smaller budgets because for
instance in Massachusetts and this is
not unusual they don't get the entire
per pupil funding the schools the kids
leave
so they walk from still get part of the
money that's attached to those kids but
in any case you know what's important
about the teacher pay is that they have
differential salaries by and large that
is the good teachers get paid more and
[Music]
and there is a pay scale that is not
simply dependent on degrees and years of
seniority which is the public school
rule and there are ladders of
opportunity within the school you can
become a mentor so you're not coming in
at 25 expecting to do the same job at 65
unless you go into administration which
a lot of teachers don't want to do so
there's a flexibility in working with
the teachers now they do get X to pay
for the long hours for instance of the
Kip to just spend and that money has to
be raised there 2700 charter schools in
36 states in the District of Columbia is
there any evidence that the charter
schools either graduate more kids more
go to college more than graduate from
college any of that too much variety in
the quality of the charter schools in
some states you've got in Arizona has
got more charter schools than I can
count
a huge variety reluctance to close them
um our view of charter schools is that
they the UM the autonomy the
accountability a flexibility provide the
preconditions for excellent education
that are not there in normal public
school settings but are they any
guarantee that you'll have good schools
absolutely not and when the schools are
not good they should be closed without
any hesitation and social grading of
public schools if I live in a community
there's a charter school and I'm middle
or high school can I go to one well you
can try to go to one but I mean all
these charter schools have snoot waiting
lists who decides what gets in
random collection random meaning putting
lottery yeah water so it's not is it
decided on race or just as no quotas or
anything like that no and in fact the
choice all the charter schools that we
talked about in the book are well race
class has got some it got Korean kids in
it so it's partly Asian but the rest of
them all either all black or all black
and Latino why is it that all your
statistics show that almost in every
category Asians and therefore percent of
the American public school students are
Asian sixty-one percent are white
seventeen percent of black and sixteen
percent of Hispanic according to your
figures why is it that the Asians in
almost every category
and I'm going to read some other
statistics here they're interesting do
better than everybody else
culture matters that is the toughest
message we've got in the book and it's
the message we thought that people were
going to have a hard time swallowing and
indeed what has astonished us in terms
of the reception to the book is the
degree to which people have said yes
she's right and I've done quite a bit of
talk radio and specifically black talk
radio where parents calling and said
she's like she's like she's right and we
have had very gratifying lis a number of
very prominent black columnist William
as Mary Clarence page right very nice
columns saying culture matters so we
good
what do we mean by culture and that's a
very important question because we
hesitated Steve and I about using the
word culture because it's got baggage it
has the implication of something like IQ
that's permanent that you can't change
and what we simply mean by culture is
are those things and skills that are
shaped and reshaped by environment
nothing permanent about it but that
nevertheless does attached to certain
racial and ethnic groups so that we can
say by and large I mean you know let's
switch let's switch away from the groups
when we talk about for a minute and
somebody said to me the other day why
did you do so well on SAT and the
obvious answer is they've been studying
for them for thousands of years I mean
that's part of the culture matters point
um Asian culture by and large you were
talking about averages here but what's
interesting is that of course when you
use the umbrella word asian you're
talking about a huge variety of group
for evan it's ridiculous to use such an
umbrella term in fact I mean you point
out Pacific Islanders who are Asian
don't do as well as well but by and
large just looking at averages Asians do
do spectacularly well in school much
better than whites in certain respects
and there are messages from the families
from these intact families about hard
work self-discipline um you ask Asian
kids whether they think grades a good
grades are due to luck or to teach us
attitudes towards them or whatever no
hard look would you go back to the
statistics again 81 percent of Asian
students have two parents in the home it
matters and and 77 percent of black kids
have only one parent now that matters
but it unfortunately I mean there is
very good statistical work on this um it
does it explains about 1/3 of the gap
well all the demographic factors
together it doesn't explain the whole
thing go to TV you write about
television then blacks watch on average
kids 5 hours of television a day an hour
more than fine kids do
and a lot more than Asian kids do how
much is that uh you know actually you
have unless my memory doesn't serve me
correctly the whites and Asian is
mysteriously don't look that different
and the black kids are watching much
more then either group like twice as
much more oh it's extremely important
pocket for watching much too much
television and they say it's their
social homework they have to watch it in
order to be part of their peer group
yeah stop there for a second define that
phrase you use it several times social
homework what is it it's what the need
to do to be socially acceptable to their
peers to be part of it part of the group
every teenager if a kid wants to be
accepted by his/her peers how much does
that have to do with a parent not being
there saying turn that off do you have
something to do is it but it also has to
do obviously with well it does have
something to do with it but the what I
was going to say also has something to
do with with the peer culture that gets
going but look the extraordinary thing
about about Asians is not simply that
the parents are saying and and the
Asians are watching quite a bit of
television we can't couldn't quite
figure out how they're watching so much
television and they're doing much more
homework than then any of their
classmates watch included um so either
they're exaggerating the amount of
television in order to feel that they
sound American or they're putting
television in the background in and
doing homework whatever week we all know
the answer to that but look the
extraordinary thing about Asians is not
simply that their parents deliver the
message but could they listen to their
parents and we have a we have a
quotation from my Asian mother who says
I don't know I teaches my children's
teachers say they want me to be a friend
of my children but
that's not our way we're not friends of
our children we're parents and and we
also have you mentioned the King Academy
which is a Kipp Academy here in what you
hear in Washington DC where the director
of T has to say to a mother you are not
your child's friend your child needs a
mother so it's not only that the Asian
that the messages from the parents are
very strong and very clear and there is
a belief and their scars in their eyes
about America and you know you do well
and you'll do well in America you do
well in school and you'll do well in
America I think intercity blacks are
much more depressed about and that's
important about what the possibilities
are for them and their kids and it is
important for the schools to to again be
delivering a message about about all
that's of it but these Asian kids live a
little off my train of thought here but
they listen to their parents let me ask
you this then because you've got 2001
statistics on the freshmen class in the
following colleges and the percentage of
the freshman class that are Asian MIT in
your neighborhood 27% Stanford 25%
Caltech 24 University of Pennsylvania 19
University of Columbia University 18
Harvard 17% of the freshman class Asian
Brown and Yale 12% no 15% of brown and
Yale and 12% at Duke and Princeton how
does this happen and you see a movement
now there's been a lot of discussion
about this where people are worried that
they're going to be too many Asians and
try to prevent that from happening going
into these colleges you know there is
there are murmurings of that sort and
and you left out the California system
Asians are four percent of the American
population they're ten percent of the
state of California they've got about 50
percent of the to flagship schools that
is you feel a and Berkeley
how does this happen well a huge
difference between Asian and whites
actually in terms of SAT score
especially on in math and but also
Advanced Placement course taking these
students are working so hard and again
they see school as their ticket and
there has been a certain amount of
resentment and indeed I was this is the
number of years ago now I was on
crossfire and the host said to me you're
going to be satisfied when these schools
are all Asians and we're told that
California's schools specifically at
that point and I feel like sending what
are we talking about the Yellow Peril
here I mean this is you know that's a
very ugly question these kids earned
their way into it on the back of your
book I want to mention who you have
endorsing that this is proponent for
American black and white which is
another book it's going to say don't
make that up no I'm not but I was
interested is Linda Chavez Tom Sol
Shelby Steele Alan wolf James Q Wilson
and Henry Louis Gates how did you get
Henry Louis Gates chairman of the
Department of afro-american studies at
Harvard to endorse that book he read it
and he said by God they've got a good
book here and you know was extremely
grateful to him um he's intellectually
willing to read books and to say okay
you know you gotta say I can't remember
how much of the quotation is there but
in the original quotation from him he
does say he disagrees with us some well
he named specifically on the question of
racial preferences and admission to
institutions of higher education but he
says nevertheless how often does it
happen that because you are the authors
you and your husband Stephen are the
authors of a book
this a lot of people in either education
people belong to unions people who are
African Americans or Hispanics just
automatically disagree with it you have
an argument just over the fact that you
did it it happened left with this book
then with American black and white and I
can't quite figure out why and indeed
our agents say more controversy we want
more controversy um
the interesting thing at one television
program I got into an argument about
whether black children needed a black
curriculum which I certainly don't
believe but the other guests did I
really think this sort of thing is black
mass um and then interestingly but this
has been it's been to some degree public
to some degree private in the form of
emails and things we're kind of certain
amount of flack from what I would call
the hard right who are very distressed
about the fact that we say loud and
clear this is not an IQ problem which we
believe it is not an IQ problem into
kids who have been needlessly shamefully
left behind the title of your book is no
excuses where does that come from well
the schools we describe are often called
no excuses school summoned that predated
the title of this book but we have a
larger meaning to to it oh we think of
it in larger terms and that is our
message is no excuses to the schools
that are failing to teach these kids no
excuses to the kids who are failing to
meet the school's halfway if you can
come to school on time with your
homework done you don't listen in class
if you wander in and out if you spend
half your school day in the hall if you
are
spending a considerable amount of time
with the school dealing with you as a
discipline problem you know you're not
eating the school halfway so no excuses
of schools no excuses to the teachers
this responsibility all around here no
excuses to the kids no excuses to the
parents who keep a child home when the
child needs when the parent needs a
babysitter or whatever or don't get that
kid out of the out of the house
first thing in the morning on time
dressed properly um so you know just
period no excuses America because these
are our kids I mean we cannot as a
society go on with a racially
identifiable group of educational half
knots it just it's poisonous how long
have you and Stephen Johnston been
married it'll be 45 years and up this
January third where did you meet and how
the Graduate School studying what he was
studying American history actually in
the program on the Greece and American
civilization and at the time I was
studying if you can believe it
Middle Eastern politics and and flipping
Arabic cards when he first laid eyes on
Richard at a lecture by I of stone we
were both very politically left I grew
up in a very politically left household
work
croton-on-hudson New York which was
known at the time for a lot of members
of the American Communist Party and
fellow travelers and it was a very good
aspect to that yeah I led a very
racially integrated life
and I've never forgotten the values of
my parents with respect to racial
equality and that that has that's been
good anyway we met it and I have stone
lecture the voice out of the leftist
past in America and I was flipping
Arabic cards where is he from many your
husband's um he is from Battle Creek
Michigan and before that poor here in
Michigan very very different family and
one my family in my teens moved to New
York City and not small-town America
have you had children two children how
old are they today 36 and 39 what kind
of schools did they go - they went to
public schools in in Lexington well
public schools in Los Angeles and then
Lexington he was teaching at UCLA for a
while and then they both went to Harvard
have you ever taught yes at Harvard I
have for how long let me see I had a
lectureship for three years and then we
went to England for a year I gave it up
and I came back on a visiting basis to
teach constant American constitutional
law when somebody was taking leave that
is my field actually is his common law
and and I decided and I've had a couple
of other visiting if I had a very very
nice offer from Berkeley upon the point
and I nearly decided after that year
coming back to teach at Harvard that I
didn't want to teach I wanted to write
which is what I love doing in what I'm
better at I go with who you are take
this book and what you've learned in all
your studies and put yourself in the
District of Columbia where I think they
spent as much as fifteen thousand
dollars of student and don't have very
good success and you're a black woman's
single and you've got a kid what would
you recommend and you don't you're not
very you know you may have a high school
degree or something like that and you
want your kid to have the
best and not get trapped in the racial
gap what would you do well course DC has
a potential voucher program on the table
and I would really push let's say you
know vouchers yet and you're you want to
do something right now you got to
support your kid and you got a screen
blush murder in the local school if you
don't think your kid is being properly
taken care of but you got to support
your kid in the ways that I've already
suggested your child has to do homework
regularly be at school so many kids that
are not really at school they are
dropouts now they're not officially
counted as such they have in effect
dropped out of school they have checked
out their erratically or they've checked
out and you know in the earlier years
they've already checked out any child
that's not reading by third grade bells
of alarm should go off in a parent's
head as well as teachers instead of oh
well you shall read later whatever
really to the best of your ability keep
track of what's going on that's hard for
parents it was hard for me to do that
because partly because I didn't
understand what what I was looking at in
school I would say again you don't
really know what it is it should be
expected of a child I mean how you imply
in here that if you haven't learned it
by a certain age you haven't got that
base you're in trouble yeah though I
would say darris come in Kipp schools
remember middle schools and there are
some high schools that are turning kids
lives around it gets lighter and lighter
though um look you do the best you can
to deliver the message to your kid that
this is a country with its arms wide
open for young people with skills and
talent
and i'ma skills and knowledge and you
you school matters I mean you cannot it
it's more important to lead lead to your
kid by the way as a parent you should
read to you what if you're not a reader
but you just have an instinct I want my
kid to be the best and have the best
education and you're just you know is
there a place to go is there money
available to get them out of a public
school system is not doing well all
those kind of things
well there is in many cities I I don't
actually know the DC scene but there are
a lot of privately funded scholarships
that do get children out of the regular
public schools and a lot of them into
parochial school if I had I hate to say
it but if I had 1,800 2,200 whether the
parochial school charges and I thought
the local propio school was doing a very
good job I hate to say it because I am a
believer in public education local
schools by and large are doing a much
better job simple reasons they have a
disciplined atmosphere they're serious
about zeroing in on the core subject
what would you do with your child when
it comes to the social homework that's
so important I mean you go too far and
here's to talk about not allowing kids
to where their their genes down around
their knees I mean you know the whole
thing to not allow it the parents can't
can't assume that burden all along okay
you know I'll get you asked where did we
meet we have children in the last panel
oh go back to my own family because it's
only because it's somewhat sympathetic
to this social homework question my kids
watched very little television because
they had these terrible parents they
were allowed to watch on Saturday
mornings but by the time I got to
Saturday mornings they couldn't remember
their watched television and the only
television was in our bedroom when we
went to bed early there was a cost of
course there was a cost to that
and I'm very aware of it and how are
they um there was a disconnect from
their peer group they were to some
extent social isolates
did they learn to be alone yeah I don't
think that's a bad skill learn to be
alone it's hard to do that to your kids
and I'm sure my kids would do it to
their kids so there are trade-offs but
you know you got to keep your eye on the
prize and the prize is doing well in
American society doors are open well
your parents educated yes they were how
many degrees um well my father just
short of a college degree and my mother
and the reason I'm hesitating this my
mother died while I was fairly young I
think she did manage to get her college
degrees these parents um his father went
through only eighth grade with books in
both of your families um
books in my family yes in his family
um yes to some extent even though his
mother was only a high school graduate
and again his father only eighth grade
his father his father read meters Digest
and worked on his vocabulary and had the
vocabulary as a consequence of a very
educated person Steve was thrilled when
he wrote an article for Reader's Digest
because it had been his father's
education and but and Steve was a total
delinquent in school and not at all
interested until they moved from portion
until to Bell Creek where he was
socially isolated and then he took Latin
and his mother insisted that school
wasn't going to let him take Latin um
his mother went down to the school and
said my child is taking Latin and it
turned him around that and debate and he
went to a he actually doesn't have a BA
he went to a school
each with the BS in public speaking he
went on a debate scholarship so you both
of you've got Harvard degrees I'm not on
the Graduate but pH days yes and both of
your kids have Harvard degrees yes you
can imagine people saying what how could
she possibly know the problems of
inner-city school I don't know all the
problems of an inner-city school but I
am an American I'm part of the society
I've had a at the writing over issues of
race and ethnicity for 20 years now I
spent a really a lot of time at these
schools and I mean this is going to
sound ridiculous and I care I mean I
don't regard these kids is somebody
else's kids
why is the right-wing upset about this
book and think that it's an IQ problem
well I just said some I went that the
flack we've gotten interestingly enough
has been left from the left that mean um
well there is a look look there are a
lot of people who believe that IQ does
is very important and you don't Steve
has been a long student of IQ he is even
though I'm a political scientist and
he's the American historian he is really
he's got a sign on his desk numbers
speak louder than words he is a totally
quantitate doesn't ask any questions but
don't have a head quantitative answer
he's been a long student of IQ and he
simply
doesn't buy it i cute intelligence
coefficient or intelligence quotient
cloture motion and you know what yours
is and oh and i don't know what his is
either but do people know I mean how do
we know who knows who someone's IQ what
someone's IQ is uh I don't know but
there's groups certain amount of yeah
been a certain amount of IQ testing and
social physics is a literature
it's a very good question I don't know
the answer to I have asked it with the
schools that we look at I have looked at
or that I have looked at very closely
and the answer is no the public schools
do it I think probably not because it's
going to differ from district to
district though I've got to ask this
just as we're getting near the end are
you glad that you went on the Civil
Rights Commission yes I am I am glad
because I because of race remains as I
said at the very beginning of this
interview it means the American dilemma
you know poisonous in American society
and because it is important and by now
to understand that these issues have
gotten very complicated race relation
racial attitudes is missing letters are
very very complicated and we need a
diversity of voices how much how much of
what we see on our c-span television
screens when we cover the Commission's
between you and Mary Francis Barry is
personal and how much of it is
professional the personal is the
political for her what does I mean she
can't separate the two you can't
separate the two
I really believe that I can totally I
have also two friends who I really
disagree with on fundamental issues but
I get along with those I love them in
some cases so the cover of the book our
guest has been the co-author Abigail
Thernstrom with her husband Steven turns
Tim and then title of this book is no
excuses closing the racial gap and
learning and we thank you very much
thank you for having me van